in 1972 as a 29 year old kid
because i was a local official was too
hard
they know where you live
and so uh
you think i'm kidding it's not a joke
marriage carry
the quality of the people's lives on
your shoulders
everything you do every day affects
their lives more than almost anything
anybody else does
and you can make or break a person's day
will the bus get me home on time
it sounds
silly but will the garbage be picked up
well i could be safe walking in the park
these are the bigger questions
can i afford
can afford to give my family a good life
will my kids
have a chance
to get a good job someday
how will i rebuild from the fire of the
storm
you know all of these questions they're
not partisan but they're practical
people you look to
whether you they're the people you look
that they look to or you for real
you know there's no way to walk into the
corner drugstore without being accosted
immediately as to what's going on right
well
so you know what it means to solve real
problems
to be held accountable for the people
you serve
that's why when i put together my
cabinet i called on former mayors and i
mean it sincerely
take a look
tom vilsack who's the governor who's
also mayor marcia fudge governor i'm an
excuse to be the mayor
marty walsh from mayor in boston pete
bloodage is a mayor
and i picked mitch landrieu to oversee
the implementation of the infrastructure
law which is over a billion 200 million
dollars because he knows how mayors get
things done
no i mean it
not a joke
because mayors know the measure of
success isn't scoring partisan points is
did you fix the problem
did you fix it seriously think about it
did you fix the problem
the infrastructure law is a perfect
example
of what we can achieve when we tackle
problems the way mayors do
everybody in america
everybody in america knows we've fallen
behind in infrastructure
so we came together
democrats and republicans and did
something about it
a number of really brave and i'm not
being facetious and i say the brave
republicans stood up and joined us in a
bipartisan effort to get it done
and by the way i want to thank you all
more than 360 of you signed a letter
sent to me
and we were trying to get the sentence
in past 360 of you
you lobbied congress to get it done
and it's the reason it got done not a
joke it's the reason it got done because
of you
[Applause]
a lot of people wanted to vote for it
but they had a lot of pressure not to
vote for it for political reasons
but because of you
they voted for it we got it done
because they know they know
how it goes in your cities to determine
how their states go
and now after years of dead ends and
broken promises
not only has infrastructure week finally
arrived
but
[Applause]
we can literally because you look
forward to an infrastructure decade
that's not hyperbole
back in 2009 when president obama asked
me to lead the
recovery effort
which was an 800 billion dollar effort
and the first thing i did i went to the
mayors not a joke
now most of you were too young to have
been around in 2008 but uh
but look i spoke to over 200 mayors
putting that together
because of them
because of you
we came through that moment together
that's the same approach that mitch has
taken
having been a former merit with all of
you
i know mitch has spoken to many of you
already
and in just two months we've already
seen this law start to make a real
difference creating better jobs
transforming our communities in tangible
ways
we've announced billions of dollars for
highways ports airports water and sewage
systems high-speed internet
funding to clean up the rivers in ohio
chemical plants and sites in florida
polluted
in michigan and dozens of other sites
a new program to cap and plug orphaned
oil and gas wells spewing methane into
the air cleaning up the communities that
in fact are affecting while good paying
jobs the folks who dug those wells
when we needed them they got paid well
well they're getting paid the same
amount to plug those wells it matters
it matters
a new initiative to bolster our energy
grid with stronger transmission lines
and towers to keep the power flowing
more reliably and consequently
more more secure energy supply
you know i've flown all over the world
all over the country these last this
last year visiting
sites that have been damaged by the
consequence of environmental changes
you know
more
more
forests
homes buildings
business has been burned to the ground
that make up if you're taking the square
miles then the entire state of new
jersey
from new york
all the way down to cape henlopen
that's how much is burned to the ground
a lot of it because of the lack of
resilience in those those towers that
get blown over the wires snap
we've got a lot so much we can do
with this legislation now
last week we rolled out a historic
investments in our nation's bridges
like the one visiting new hampshire
where restrictions we could force school
buses and fire trucks to go 10 miles out
of the way
just to get across a small river
or the i-10 bridge i visit in
louisiana it's 20 years past this
planned life
it doesn't have modern safety fissures
features
and it's last inspected the bridge the
bridge is deemed to be in poor condition
and now it has
two lanes on the bridge okay
that in a four-lane interstate feeds
into
creating and causing major backups we're
gonna upgrade thousands of bridges
creating good paying jobs cutting
commute times ensuring that as we build
back
no community gets me left behind
folks
that mayor's
view of problem solving exactly what we
brought to the american rescue plan
it's designed so that you'd be able to
have the resources and the flexibility
to take both the short-term and
long-term challenges created by this
pandemic
ten months ago
that law is still carrying the nation
forward
on vaccines on boosters on keeping
schools open
and still making a difference for
communities across the country
and i might add
a lot of money in that to keep those
schools open
some states have spent the money well
gotten at you all so you can in fact
keep those schools open and
change the ventilation system and change
the business and all the whole works
some states haven't
distributed money
everything i've done my career
when it comes to federal funding
i've tried to make sure
that you don't have to go past go to get
it it goes directly to the mayors
[Applause]
a major part of the rescue plan was the
350 billion dollars we allocated to
state local budgets and again because of
you
over a million hundred billion of that
went directly to cities and counties not
for anybody
[Applause]
it was not easy to get done but it's
important to get done because you know
what's needed
you don't have to go through your state
legislature they're not bad folks i
don't mean that
or your governor good folks
to get the money
today communities are still putting
those funds to work keeping people on
the job
connecting people to better jobs in
seattle
the money is being used to give premium
pay to local child care workers
so they can keep child care centers open
and available for folks who need it not
sure that would have happened and not
gone directly to the states i mean fro
had gone directly to the states
you know in phoenix partner with
community college these funds are going
to help workers find careers in region
and
regions and in the semiconductor
industry which is a big big deal
in milwaukee
you all are training workers to get help
to get rid of
lead pipelines you have 450 000 school i
mean the idea
that we have our kids drinking out of
fountains
that have lead pipes feeding the
fountains
because everybody deserves clean water
everybody no matter where your city
suburban
or rural areas
here in washington dc
it's funding the expansion of an
infrastructure academy
preparing local workers to take the good
paying jobs in manufacturing
construction and utilities that are
going to be created as a consequence of
the infrastructure law
look i urge every american
to take a look at what you all are doing
urge every mayor in america to follow
suit
to use the resources
the rescue plan
the resources that were intended not
just to stave off disaster but the bill
for a future
around the people who make communities
run
use your funds to cover child care costs
or temporary paid leave to help certain
workers dealing with omicron
build pathways to better jobs
through union-based apprenticeships on
on-the-job training
to give people in every zip code a
chance to deal for themselves
and deal them into this booming economy
that also means building more affordable
housing so people can have safe places
closer to their jobs
funding proven programs to help fight
violent crime we shouldn't be cutting
funding for police departments
i propose increasing funding
look
you know we ask cops to do everything
including be psychologists and social
workers
guess what they need psychologists and
so-called social workers
[Applause]
no i mean not a joke
so they can hire more social workers
folks folks trained in mental health so
they can partner with trusted community
leaders
like the programs the rescue plan is
funding in atlanta and louisville
and other cities across the country the
truth is we have an incredible
opportunity
ahead of us this year we still have a
lot of work to do to defeat cohen to
bring down costs for families
but just look at what we've accomplished
together so far
even in the face of those headwinds
in 2021 more jobs are created in america
than ever in a single year in american
history
more jobs over 6 million
unemployment rate dropped more than any
year in american history
income
incomes for working frontline jobs in
service industries rose more than any
year in history the folks at the bottom
of the economic ground
we lowered child poverty in this country
by nearly 40 percent more than any time
in the us system
[Applause]
you all know this business applications
grew by nearly 30 percent
last year more than any year in history
if there's nothing so bad why are people
fighting to open up businesses
more americans gain health insurance
than any year in history
these are facts
to confront the climate crisis we
deployed more solar wind
batteries and electric vehicles than
ever ever before
we're teaming up with mayors labor and
industry to save families and businesses
money by improving energy efficiency in
our buildings
and in the battle against the deadly
virus
we've gone from putting two million
shots of vaccinations in people's arms
to
210 million americans fully vaccinated
[Applause]
the new mayors have been critical
partners i'm not trying to be nice to
you it's just a fact you've been
critical partners in that fight from day
one
from masking the testing to vaccinations
we partner with you
we partnered with you on the mayor's
challenge last summer 115 cities working
together to get americans vaccinated in
richmond mayor stoney you created
vaccination clinics that doubled the job
fair and doubled his job fairs get your
shot and it's also a job fair
encouraging people to come in
in detroit mayor duggan
are you here mr mayor
i tell you what i work with him for a
long time there's a man knows what he's
doing mayor duggan partnered with solar
saloons and barber shops to get shots in
people's arms and saint louis mayor
jones work with churches and local food
programs to reach neighborhoods with low
vaccination rates
all these efforts you've saved lives not
a joke you've saved lives
now to keep up that fight against
omicron we've launched dozens of federal
testing sites in new york philadelphia
henderson nevada and elsewhere
throughout sites that we're launching
every week
we've devoted federal medical teams made
up of military
first responders national guard to bring
relief to the hardest hit hospitals who
need additional personnel just to keep
it moving because they're so overrun
we're purchasing and distributing free
one billion
at-home tests to people can test
themselves in their communities
and we still face tremendous challenges
though but together we've proven that we
can get big things done in this country
last year you helped we laid the
groundwork this year we have to build it
the biggest weapon in our arsenal is the
build back better act
nothing's going to do more to ease
pressure on families
as
as my friend jim clyburn says it's all
about making everything more affordable
and more accessible to people
every mayor knows that people can't find
affordable child care they can't work
some of your cities it's 14 15 000 bucks
a year for child care
that's why we have nearly 1.2 million
extremely qualified women who haven't
been able to return to the workforce
we can cut the cost of child care in
half
and fix that problem
health insurance we can reduce the cost
for families we've done for six hundred
dollars per year
on climate extreme weather disaster
costs communities 104
billion last year that's how much we
spent because of weather related crises
145 billion dollars
by investing in resilience and clean
energy technology we can do something
about that
to give relief to families in the
american rescue plan we had the child
care tax credit
that did reduce child property by 40
percent there's no reason it shouldn't
continue
and an education
[Applause]
on education today about half
of the three and four-year-olds are
enrolled in early childhood education in
germany france uk latvia the number is
more than 90 percent
where the heck are we
[Music]
no i'm serious we're falling further and
further behind the curve
but we can fix that problem
we can do this and more on health care
nutrition a host of other issues and
folks here's the point we can do it
without increasing inflation or the
deficit 17 nobel laureates in the
economics
wrote a letter
to me recently affirming that this bill
would reduce inflationary pressures on
the economy i'd agree reduce it
and by the way
by the way
it's entirely paid for
every single penny
and not a single person
making less than four hundred thousand
dollars a year will pay a single
additional penny in federal taxes not a
single penny
[Applause]
and by the way
i'm a capitalist i'm not a socialist now
if you can make a billion dollars 10
million dollars good for you
just begin to pay your fair share
pay a little bit
[Applause]
we can pay for all this by just making
sure that the wealthy
making sure that the wealthy and the
biggest corporations pay their fair
share case in point
last two years 55
of the fortune 500 companies
and i come from the corporate capital of
the world
delaware not a joke
more corporations incorporated into my
state than every other state in the
union okay i get it and i represented it
for 36 years
but guess what
you got 55 corporations last year
that made
40 billion dollars in profits and didn't
pay a single penny in taxes
that's not right
that's not right look we can tackle all
these challenges
just like we did with the rescue plan
the infrastructure law and the fight
against covet
but we can't do it without you i'm not
trying to be nice to you we can't do it
without you
no really that's the god's truth
you understand the challenges people are
facing
and you understand the solutions
you know this isn't when it gets down to
whether the garbage gets collected or
someone is safe in the street this isn't
partisan it's practical
you understand the cost
if we fail to ask
we need the voice of mayors
telling the stories
of what your community's needs
and the impact
we're making on people's lives or not
making
we can get this done
i believe this will every fiber in my
being if we can get this done there's no
limit what americans can achieve
so let's continue to give
working families a fighting chance
i wasn't kidding when i said when i
announced for president
that i am so tired
of the working class and middle class
carrying the burden
it's about time we grow the economy from
the bottom up in the middle out and by
the way
when the middle class does well the
wealthy do very very very well
i'm not joking this isn't about
punishing anybody
about getting everybody in the game
raise your hand if you think the
president tax structure is fair
and we'll take a picture of you and send
it home
[Applause]
seriously guys
you know
the thing i like about mares is you're
straight you know what i mean you just
you
you shoot from the shoulder
so let's keep investing in the future of
every city in town in america
let's face these challenges head on
and keep building we can go back better
folks i really believe it there's not a
damn thing we can't do if we set our
minds to it
and every single time
think about this now it's not hyperbole
no other country than america
has come through every crisis we faced
and ended up stronger than we were
before we got into the crisis
think about that
think about that
so don't give up on the american people
you know i've said many many times
to world leaders particularly when they
asked me about america
it's never been a good bet to bet
against the american people never never
never been a good bet to get them
bet against american people
now we stand together there's not a damn
thing we can't do
democrat and republican
thank you all and god bless you
may god protect our troops keep it going
folks we need you badly we need
[Applause]